second débat dans ce sens public vous
savez il est plus prospectif
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour avec ce chiffre entre 800 mille et
un million d'enfants victimes chaque
année de harcèlement scolaire en france
une loi sur ce thème est en cours
d'examen au sénat avant d'en débattre le
témoignage de laetitia son fils a été
harcelé pendant plusieurs années par un
camarade de classe plus que l'école que
la justice c'est finalement une
association qui l'a aidé reportage à
ouistreham a signé cécile
cavani à 12 ans de la maternelle au cm2
il a été harcelé par un autre élève de
son école enfin charles maternelle est
un enfant et un élève qui arrêtait pas
de frapper le marché les
mesures de menaces
et c'était ça jusqu'à 18 ans je me
sentais pas bien parce que c'est
énervant stressant on peut se faire
harceler d'affaires a baissé
se faire insulter se faire menacer se
faire frapper aussi très vite li titien
sa maman a vu son fils des pays et maux
de ventre pleurs insomnies ces notes
sont en chute libre et il change de
comportement il s'est renfermé
il est devenu un petit peu agressif
envers ses soeurs
les dernières années a surtout l'année
de cm2 et rentre en conflit avec son
papa en permanence on a vu son
comportement à l'école changer également
c'est à dire que lui qui était
respectueux envers les adultes a
commencé à répondre aux professeurs
il est ici a fait appel à l'association
stop harcèlement elle interpelle l'école
lui rectorat et la mairie dépose plainte
contre l'enfant à soleure mais rien ne
bouge elle se sent démuni
ça a été très dur parce qu'on voit son
enfant qui qui va pas bien qui est pas
bien
et on sait plus quoi faire ré cette
impression de n'avoir personne à qui
parler n'avoir personne qui nous
écoutent surtout qu'ils comprennent la
détresse de notre enfant à des treize
familiale parce que faut pas oublier
qu'un enfant qui n'est pas bien la
famille également ne va pas bien parce
qu'on se pose des questions on se
demande ce qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'on a
mal fait ce qu'on n'a pas vu ce qu'on
aurait pu faire un jour laetitia en ont
parlé d'une association de motards qui
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
vers laquelle elle se tourne
bonjour
donc j'ai appelé starborn donc roxy à
qui m'a écouté je me souviens je
pleurais jour là j'étais vraiment à bout
de nerfs avait fait plus quoi faire
et là elle m'a tout de suite dire
t'inquiète pas on va être là elle trop
l'un roxy la présidente a eu une idée
simple rassembler du biker devant
l'établissement d'un enfant harceler
pour dissuader ses agresseurs de s'en
prendre à lui vous enfants comprennent
que par ses paires assez justice du mans
et bien si certains leur permettent
d'arrêter c'est juste gagner
lars eller dans cette voie et que cet
enfant a protégé et du coup 1 du coup
ils ont tendance à avoir peur donc
l'effet de l'effet de masse devant un
établissement de motards
impressionne une démonstration de force
qui est un marché immédiatement pour
cavani
mettez vous un l'arsenal arrêtés et
certains ce n'est pas ce que
j'ai c'est que cette crise était là
pendant et après du court
je ne sortais pas cela
avant toute intervention l'association
réalise un entretien avec l'enfant et
vérifie qu'une plainte a été déposée
après roxy suit les enfants harcelés
jusqu'à leurs 18 ans quand c'est
d'autres soucis on ré intervient et à
savoir en fait que j'appelle chaque
enfant j'avais s'appelle en fait à peu
près une fois tous les mois ou une fois
tous les deux mois pour prendre des
nouvelles de chaque enfant ça sonne tu
sais très bien que tu peux compter sur
nous tout le temps au temps mon numéro
de téléphone un problème aussi à
l'établissement si je dois bien te
cherchais je cherchais au total ces
chevaliers blancs en blouson noir ont
réalisé 19 ans tu es invention
on débat autour du harcèlement avec mes
invités sabine vendre avec bonjour
bienvenue vous un jour sénatrice
socialiste du pas de calais ancienne
présidente de la mission sénatoriale sur
le harcèlement scolaire lucie pitiot
bonjour bonsoir proviseur de la cité
scolaire villon à paris 14e ancien
référente harcèlement scolaire au
rectorat de l'académie de strasbourg
jean pierre belon bonsoir anne soit le
professeur de philosophie fondateur de
l'association pour la prévention des
phénomènes de harcèlement entre élèves
et vous avez publié plusieurs livres sur
ce thème on est également en duplex en
visioconférence avec pauline de ville ou
13 qui est bénévole à l'association
marion la main tendue bonsoir à vous
bienvenus évidemment matthieu
croissandeau et est resté à mes côtés je
voudrais une première réaction je
commence avec voulu s'y piquer aux
reportages qu'on vient de voir moi ce
qui me frappe c'est souvent quand on
discute avec même parfois des amis qui
sont confrontés à ce fléau du
harcèlement c'est que ils ont pas ils
ont parfois j'allais dire souvent le
sentiment que l'école et la justice
répond pas et là c'est une association
qui trouvent la solution est ce que il
ya un effet loupe parce que ceux qui
parlent et qu'ils disent l'école et la
justice ne répond pas voilà ces
mécontents donc ils prennent plus la
parole ou est ce que c'est une réalité
alors de plus en plus ça ne devrait plus
être une réalité je crois qu'on a un
énorme effort depuis la vue qu'on s'est
mise à parler à peu près de harcèlement
disons dans les années 2010-2011 dans
les établissements scolaires on a fait
des progrès considérables
pour libérer la parole des enfants je
pense à la mise en place par exemple de
ce concours un harcèlement qui était
assez confidentielle au moment de sa
mise en oeuvre en 2014 et qui désormais
rassemble plus d'une plus de 40 mille
élèves qui font des productions affiche
vidéo qu'ils transmettent au ministère
de l'éducation nationale qui en fait un
vaste concours et du coup le corollaire
de ce concours c'est que dans ces
établissements là et dans l'ensemble des
établissements désormais il ya des
protocoles par rapport aux harcèlements
et on fait en sorte de libérer la parole
des élèves ont fait aussi en sorte que
les élèves témoins puissent agir
également quand ils ont vu un camarade
en danger sur tout les parents également
sache que les adultes sont là pour les
pour les entendre très honnêtement j'ai
l'impression qu'on a progressé ceci dit
c'était quoi le réflexe était ou là là
on s'attaque en dalle dans notre
établissement donc on essaie de jeter un
peu l'histoire de harcèlement moi je
vais pense qu'il faut cesser de penser
que la culture du mettons tous sous le
tapis et le panache de l'éducation
nationale je crois que là aussi on a
fait d'énormes
d'énormes progrès sans doute y at il eu
non pas une culture du silence par
rapport à ça mais peut-être une
difficulté à appréhender ce que beaucoup
d'adultes ont considéré alors comme des
chamailleries comme un passage obligé de
l'enfance de l'adolescence du renfort ce
soit ça va ça va passer ces choses là
qui sont des espèces de réflexes et et
qui sont assez courants finalement dans
la hâte dans la société et qui ont
induit peut-être les professionnels en
erreur par rapport à ce qu'ils voyaient
et xix densifier pâques une brimade à
l'intérieur d'une classe c'était du
harcèlement les parents du coup quand
l'enfant était vraiment déprimé à la
maison se sont dit mais enfin ça fait
des mois que ça dure comment se fait-il
que les adultes n'est pas réagit bien
sans doute on s'est trompé sur le
diagnostic et je crois que ça n'est plus
le cas depuis quelques années jean
pierre belon il ya une prise de
conscience ça effectivement si vous
deviez faire le bilan chez pas de la
décennie écoulée il ya un passage de
l'ombre la lumière la sainterie clair on
est resté moi j'ai commencé à travailler
sur ces questions là au début des années
2000 dont il ya plus de vingt ans on
était dans les années 2000 dans un
silence absolu est dans un déni complet
aujourd'hui une plaie institut à tout
oui tout c'était cette cécité le sujet
tabou ne voulais pas en parler c'était
le nuage de tchernobyl il n'arrivait pas
chez nous tous les pays d'europe
s'intéresser à ces questions là la
france n'ont donc c'est arrivé d'un coup
par chance un conseiller du ministre de
l'époque à qu'il faudrait rendre hommage
tous les jours c'est laurent bâillon
aujourd'hui il est avocat qui a mis le
sujet sur la sur la table et c'est vrai
c'était luc chatel à l'époque ils sont
conseillés donc c'était laurent gayon il
ya eu à partir de ce moment là des
progrès absolument spectaculaire parce
qu'on a cessé tout simplement de se
boucher les yeux de ne pas regarder la
réalité en face
j'ai peur à chaque fois qu'il ya un fait
divers à chaque fois qu'ils sont
toujours terribles bien sûr qu'on voit
un peu ce phénomène j'allais dire sur un
mode un peu caricatural ce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est que ça commence comment
ça commence par une moquerie ça commence
par un sûrement ça commence par une mise
à l'écart c'est à dire une toute une
série de petites choses dont chacun peut
se dire oh c'est pas du harcèlement
c'est rien sauf que tout mis bout à bout
au bout du compte ça devient du
harcèlement donc ce qui a à mon sens
changé depuis quelques temps c'est qu'on
regarde les choses de façon beaucoup
plus attentive en attendant pas que ça
devienne du harcèlement
occupons nous de l'élève mis à l'écart
de celui qui lorsqu'on fait un exercice
ah bah tiens comme par hasard ils se
retrouvent il se retrouve tout seul et
c'est occupons nous de toutes ces
petites choses c'est comme ça qu'on
évitera ces situations terribles sabine
menet ya six à dix pour cent des élèves
qui subissent une forme de harcèlement
dans leur scolarité est ce que ces
chiffres ils sont pas un peu
sous-évaluée ce qu'on pourrait
considérer même si j'entends ce que vous
me dites là et l'autre qui a encore
beaucoup d'élèves qui n'osent pas en
parler mais qui n'en parlent pas qu'ils
n'en parle pas évidemment parce qu'ils
craignent ils craignent les représailles
j'ai présidé
la mission d'information sur le
harcèlement scolaire est là le cyber
harcèlement
on a fait énormément d'audition on a
écouté les acteurs
on a établi un rapport un rapport qui a
été adoptée à l'unanimité des membres de
la mission et ce rapport ce rapport
était basé sur un triptyque donc 35
propositions basées sur un triptyque
détecter et prévenir détecter et traiter
ou prévenir détecter et traiter donc et
aussi partie due à un plus tôt arrivé à
la conclusion qu'il n'était pas
nécessaire de créer un délit spécifique
de harcèlement oui alors on va y revenir
parce qu'effectivement c'est ce qui est
proposé dans dans la loi je vous
redonner la parole éviter pendant un
instant je voudrais entendre pauline de
villoutreys une première intervention ça
commence à quel âge je sais pas dans
l'est dans les faits de harcèlement dont
vous êtes saisis est ce que ça commence
très tôt à quel âge
alors nous on se rend compte que
finalement les phénomènes de harcèlement
arrive malheureusement de plus en plus
tôt souvent on a repéré des cas où les
enfants souvent 5 6 ans ce qui est très
jeune et sauf qu'on le remarque de plus
en plus et aujourd'hui maintenant je
dirais que finalement le harcèlement il
va être aussi bien présent à l'école
primaire et au collège et au lycée mais
voilà ce qu'on se rend compte
aujourd'hui c'est que dès la fin de
l'école maternelle on voit déjà des
phénomènes de harcèlement alors que les
enfants sont quand même en pleine
évolution en plein apprentissage et se
rendre compte qu'on a déjà des
phénomènes de harcèlement aussi jeune
c'est c'était libre
effectivement c'est assez terrible on va
revenir donc sur cette commission que
vous avez précis président et est sûre
ce cette proposition de loi la stib
jourdain peut nous rejoindre bonsoir
steve
venu donc le parlement se saisisse est
saisie de ce sujet du harcèlement
squeele comment lutter contre ce fléau
qui touche bien chaque année entre 800
mille et un million d'enfants ce fléau
qui peut aller jusqu'à bien tuer les
élèves les plus fragiles c'est la
question à laquelle députés et sénateurs
doivent répondre aujourd'hui alors une
proposition de loi a été déposée au mois
de novembre mais c'est un sujet sur
lequel bien planches le sénat depuis
plusieurs mois une mission d'information
on l'a dit avait en effet été mise en
place au printemps dernier elle avait
demandé à ce que le harcèlement devient
la grande cause nationale de la rentrée
2022 2023 il est encore temps elle avait
aussi émis une trentaine de
recommandations pour lutter contre le
harcèlement harcèlement que les
sénateurs aient bien avait alors défini
comme la stigmatisation de la différence
est trop souvent la diffusion de
préjugés sexistes sexuelle ou raciaux
tandis que prévoit la loi qui est
actuellement en discussion alors deux
choses d'abord des sanctions plus
lourdes contre les harceleurs c'est le
coeur du texte qui est actuellement
examinée puis ensuite le renforcement du
droit une scolarité sans harcèlement il
s'agit d'un droit qui avait été consacré
dans une loi adoptée en 2019 alors pour
remplir ces objectifs les députés
demandent vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure à ce qu'un délit spécifique de
harcèlement scolaire soit créé c'est la
grande mesure qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale c'était au mois de
décembre mais les sénateurs n'ont pas
été convaincus par le dispositif écouter
le rapporteur les républicains olive est
pas qu une question se pose de nouvelles
dispositions législatives sont elles
nécessaires pour mieux prévenir et
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire
alors même que le parlement à légiférer
sur le sujet il a moins de deux ans les
sanctions pénales et administratives
existe un adulte ils sont enseignants
personnels administratifs ou techniques
de l'éducation nationale ou encore
assistant d'éducation peut déjà être
poursuivi pour des faits de harcèlement
commission un élève plutôt qu'un délit
spécifique les sénateurs proposent de
faire du harcèlement une circonstance
aggravante du harcèlement moral selon le
texte du sénat qui a été adopté par le
sénat le harcèlement scolaire sera
désormais puni de 45000 euros d'amendé
et de trois ans de prison un amendement
important a aussi été adopté thomas dans
l'hémicycle il prévoit que la victime
pourra change d'établissement en dehors
des limites de la carte scolaire et puis
dernier point sur lequel les sénateurs
ont voulu insister c'est le cas du
cyberharcèlement écouter la centriste
annick billon elle-même victime il ya
quelques mois d'une forme de harcèlement
sur les réseaux écoutez là un élément
trop absents de la version issue de
l'assemblée nationale le cyber
harcèlement prolongement du harcèlement
scolaire amplifié par l'aspect meute du
phénomène via les réseaux sociaux les
tablettes ou les smartphones le cyber
harcèlement ne laisse aucun répit aux
victimes la précision était donc
nécessaire voilà pour cette année
association le texte du sénat ne va
clairement pas assez loin elle demande
aux députés de réintégrer dans le texte
le délit spécifique de harcèlement se
délient qui a donc été supprimée par les
sénateurs merci steve pour toutes ces
précisions et ça ça ouvre les thèmes
qu'on va que l'on va aborder ensemble
maintenant notamment le cyberharcèlement
évidemment il se consacrait un chapitre
cette idée de carte scolaire aussi
j'aimerais bien vous entendre là dessus
mais d'abord le délit spécifique sabine
van heghe pourquoi vous pensez qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire de créer un délit
spécifique
parce que l'arsenal juridique existe
déjà parce que le fait de stigmatiser un
enfant même s'il a causé des désordres
était l'ami des désastres achètent chez
un autre enfant appelé quand même qu'il
y à il ya eu cette année une vingtaine
de suicides d'enfants donc c'est très
grave mais le fait de l'imposer de ses
percées peine l'eau de son est inutile
pour moi c'est inutile pour nous parce
que ça va conduire à des non lieux ça va
conduire à un abandon de la de la
poursuite qui en fait va renforcer va
renforcer le harceleur dans le dans le
style doit écouter voilà c'est tout va
que tout va bien quoi on peut un peu
qu'on peut continuer on était vraiment
content ça et le fait le fait que
d'aller cet article 4 de transformer le
délit spécifique en circonstance
aggravante du délit de harcèlement qui
existe déjà nous a fait dix ont accepté
plus facilement
c'est alors je mets à vous entendre l'un
et l'autre sur sur cet aspect là jean
pierre blanc est-ce qu'il ya besoin et
où est-ce qu'on a finalement un arsenal
législatif suffisant aujourd'hui d'après
on absolument tout ce qu'il faut on a ce
qu'il faut je pense qu'il ya un contre
sens qui a été commis dès le départ d'un
par la mission qui a débouché sur le
projet de loi dans version de
l'assemblée nationale et je trouve que
le sénat très bien corriger le le texier
un contre sens on s'imagine qu'il ya
d'un côté les espèces de méchants
harceleur et puis une victime et puis
des témoins qui sont neutres je suis
désolé c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe quand il ya un surnom c'est tout
le monde qui reprendre sur nos cahiers
de mise à l'écart c'est pas trois élèves
qui vous met à l'écart c'est tout là
c'est toute la classe qu'at-il une
moquerie est le fait rire absolument
tout le monde alors c'est long c'est un
phénomène de deux meutes secondes un
phénomène de groupe et donc sur kirk est
ce qu'on va ouzou sont ses harceleurs
que que l'on va que l'on va punir les
seconds d'un délit spécifique à ce que
vous nous dites c'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut arrêter des choses dès le départ et
ce n'est pas ni à la police ni à la
justice de traiter la question du
harcèlement c'est à l'école et
prioritairement ses taux c'est aux
enseignants comptent donc cette
proposition d'un délit elle est et elle
témoigne d'une profonde méconnaissance
de la réalité du phénomène lucie pitiot
autre expérience de proviseur la grande
révolution copernicienne qu'on est en
train d'essayer d'avoir dans l'école
c'est effectivement la détection précoce
des phénomènes pour aller traiter d'une
autre façon que par la coercition ou par
la sanction il faut pas qu'ils aient une
solution coco c'est quoi une espèce de
monde à part dans lequel la justice n'a
pas ce que je veux dire c'est un peu le
sentiment qu'on a à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut des textes qu'il faut des lois et
ce qu'il faut les durcir ce qu'il faut
des sanctions plus importantes uraca je
porte il faudra qu'on interroge cette
justice d'exception qu'est la justice
scolaire dans un établissement il y à
une sanction disciplinaire en parallèle
de cela il peut y avoir effectivement
une sanction qui est posée par
l'appareil judiciaire
et parfois ces choses là sont pas tout à
fait raccord l'autre tempo et celui le
tempo de l'école celui de la justice
même quand elles veulent se veut
réparatrice ça va être un tempo très
rapide celui de la justice n'est pas du
tout le même donc un jour peut-être on
s'interrogera sur la coexistence de ces
choses là mais sur le problème très
spécifique du harcèlement ce qui me
fonctionne le mieux est désormais on a
quelques années d'expérience avec la
méthode des préoccupations partagées
c'est quand on arrive à prendre les
choses suffisamment tôt que l'on peut
déclencher chez l'élève que l'on
considère comme harceleur mais la
plupart du temps il n'est pas tout seul
effectivement il est au milieu d'un
groupe il ya des interactions à
l'intérieur ce groupe qu'on peut
déclencher chez lui un réflexe
d'empathie pour l'élève victime qu'on
appelle plutôt dans la méthode des
préoccupations partagées que monsieur b
l'on diffuse très largement mêmes
industriellement désormais au niveau des
académies
ccib la préoccupation partagée donc
c'est quoi c'est créer recréer de
l'empathie autour d'eux la ville a
suscité en fait on va faire alliance
avec l'élève qu'on appelle la cible
c'était la victime d'une situation de
harcèlement et puis on va demander aux
élèves qui sans témoin actif on voir
carrément harceleur de 7,7 élèves cible
de partager la préoccupation qui est la
nôtre qui est parfaitement sincère c'est
à dire que ce que l'on souhaite c'est
que cet élève qui est dans une situation
de grande fragilité qui est
qui est isolé qui est brimé ne
ressentent plus cette extrême solitude
cette extrême violence qui c'est qui
s'exercent sur lui lorsque nous aurons
partager cette préoccupation avec ses
receveurs et qu'ils vont cesser ils vont
trouver eux mêmes des ressources pour
faire cesser cette situation si on fait
cesser la situation alors seulement on a
gagné sans avoir besoin d'en passer par
la sanction et ça c'est une véritable
révolution à votre permission ceci étant
il ya des moments où c'est trop tard
quand le dossier arrive sur sur sur le
bureau et que l'élève est dans une
situation de détresse et ça m'est arrivé
encore récemment quand vous recevez une
élève qui littéralement liquide en face
de vous qui a reçu pendant des mois des
brimades et qui s'est tu pendant des
mois sur ces situations n'en a pas parlé
non plus à sa famille tout d'un coup a
craché le morceau elle l'a craché haut
dans mon bureau elle a craché après à
son père le père m'appelle en larmes en
me disant mon enfant hier soir a
totalement craqué si vous ne faites plus
de choses je craint pour sa vie c'est
trop tard là à dire que ce processus
dont vous parliez il est plus à grand
chose à ce moment là à ce moment là on
est coincé un peu plus le mettre en
oeuvre et qu'est ce qui se passait bien
à ce que selon vous parlais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que
le premier réflexe c'est de juin les
autorités académiques ce qui s'est passé
le lendemain 15 décembre c'était là va
changer d'établissement mais oui mais ça
c'est mathieu cécé je me dire cela mais
c'est ce que j'ai dit
l'éducation nationale qui vaut pour le
harcèlement qui vaut parfois pour
l'antisémitisme dans certains
établissements les mieux de permettre
votre enfant ici parce que vous êtes
trop compliqué parce que c'est plus
facile d'en recaser inclus dans recaser
10 ou 12 pour le coup c'était une
question d'urgence c'est-à-dire que
j'entends louis l'élève ni sa famille ne
se voit y ait un avenir
dans l'établissement et dans cette
proximité est facilitée va exister quand
même de déplacer la cible comme dit tout
à fait tout ça une action au niveau
affectivement allez voir cela mais moi
je me suis exactement la même réflexion
mathieu jean pierre blaess qu'on a le
choix finalement quand on est
proviseur directeur d'établissement
parce que nous alors faux faux faux
faire faut virer la moitié de la classe
où les trois quarts de la caci l'a62 le
harcèlement et à un phénomène de groupe
donc peut-être que la seule solution
c'est d'exfiltrer paravent du terme la
victime lorsqu'on est arrive dans des
situations de ce type effectivement
peut-être qu'ils n'y a rien d'autre à
faire mais c'est ultra choquant pour les
parents c'est une
vraie question est de savoir pourquoi on
en est arrivé là qu'on ne vienne pas me
dire je ne le croirais pas qu'on n'a
rien vu on a tous vu un petit peu
quelque chose qu'un élève qui émir qui
mis à l'écart un élève qui est moqué qui
ridiculise et ça se passe où ça se passe
sous les yeux des adultes donc ces
phénomènes sont vus donc arrêtons de
encore une fois de nous boucher les yeux
parce que même si on a accompli de très
grands progrès en l'espace de dix ans il
reste un certain nombre de zones dans
lesquelles on continue à dire cette
question comme moi je ne voudrais plus
entendre à mai à partir du concept
commence ça devient du harcèlement mais
n'attendons pas que ça devient ça
devienne du harcèlement traitant les
choses traitant les choses tout de suite
hélas lorsqu'on regarde les situations
qui ont débouché sur des suicides et
tentatives de suicide quand on regarde
un petit peu en amont on s'aperçoit que
très souvent il ya eu des défaillances
donc cessons ces défaillances qui ne
cuisent ne doivent plus exister dans les
établissements il ya quand même quelques
jours une défaillance à dire quoi on a
sous-estimé
la détresse des victimes on n'a pas
voulu voir et quand même quelque chose
qui est en train de se mettre en place
depuis à titre expérimental à partir de
2019 et
alors ça je vais y venir dans un instant
pardon de vous interrompre et je
voudrais donner la parole à pauline de
vie du xiii qu'on a relativement peu
pour entendu à quel moment vous
intervenez avec votre association parce
que vous êtes amenés dans les écoles
c'est ça oui on a intervient pour
l'école on va aussi intervenir dans les
centres de loisirs les centres sportifs
mais aussi les mairies qu en fait on va
intervenir à partir du moment où on a
des écoles ou des familles qui nous
appellent parce que soit ils ont envie
qu'on vienne elle faisait pour faire de
la prévention tout simplement parce
qu'il ya eu des faits de harcèlement ou
souvent ils savent pas trop à quoi ça
corresponde c'est vrai que par exemple
il ya dix ans moi je connaissais pas du
tout cette notion ça fait maintenant
quatre cinq ans qu'on en parle vraiment
sérieusement de ce fléau et aussi donc
ils vont nous appeler pour cela et nous
on va se rendre compte que logiquement
c'est pas pour rien qu'ils nous
appellent et que justement on doit l
associant le terrain pour justement
expliqué c'est quoi le harcèlement comme
on l'est vite quelles sont les missions
qu'on peut apporter pour justement
lutter contre ce fléau et c'est dans ces
cas là qu'on va surtout à intervenir et
deuxième chose c'est aussi beaucoup de
familles qui vont nous appeler pour des
demandes de soutien on a eu l'année
dernière cinq mille demandes et 2900
s'appelle ce qui n'est pas rien rejoint
du coup ce que disait jean pierre boulot
en disant qu' on a forcément déjà vu
dans notre vie on a déjà été témoin
d'une scène de harcèlement donc pour moi
il faut pas rester bouche bée et agir
tout de suite ne pas attendre finalement
que le harcèlement se produisent pour
agir dès qu'on a un doute qu'on voit
quelqu'un à l'écart convoité jacquier
pas bien quelle ne fût des résultats
scolaires qui subit de la phobie
scolaire c'est là où il faut agir en
fait pour justement éviter que des
enfants meurent ou face à ces tentatives
de suicide on a 95 % des familles que
l'on reçoit ou au moins un enfant avait
déjà fait au moins une tentative de
suicide ce qui doit alerter mais si
sabine van heghe il faut réunir
harcelés et harceleurs finalement quand
on parle de ses programmes ici ou
d'expérience we hate à gémir les uns les
autres oui alors je reviens sur ce que
disait ce que disait madame moi je salue
l'action des associations ils viennent
vraiment en renfort de l'école et aussi
il est évident qu'il ya un manque de
formation un manque de formation de
personnels enseignants et même de tout
le personnel entourant la ville enfants
on a on a pu constater lors de nos
auditions que 75 % des personnels des
enseignants se trouvait un peu démuni en
termes de formation à la détection la
détection du
si compliqué
il faut
des moyens les moyens à des moyens à
développer à promouvoir pour pour en
termes de formation des enseignants dans
ce domaine et oui il faut il faut réunir
harceleur harceler des réunions
d'information bien sûr bien sûr le temps
est compté pour les enseignants
ils sont un peu près 1 pas prêt il n'ya
pas de temps mais des temps dédié je
pense en début de trimestre peuvent être
consacrés à des réunions d'information
même avec les parents et tous le tous
les élèves et même avec pourquoi pas des
harceleurs d harceler bons qui sont ils
ont repentis mais pour expliquer ce
qu'est le harcèlement c'est
les moyens les moyens de se confier et
d'en parler pour pouvoir enrayer alors
le programme phare on prend plusieurs
minutes dans ce débat pour faire un gros
plan sur le programme phare pour
programme de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire
testé depuis deux ans et qui a été
déployé dans l'ensemble des écoles et
les collèges depuis le mois de septembre
dernier jean pierre belon
est ce que ces deux là encore une
avancée est ce que ça si ça marche ça
peut faire de la france un pays un peu
inquiets tech est passé de rétrograde à
pilote si ça marche on aura probablement
le plan le plus ambitieux de lutte
contre le harcèlement puisque quand même
l'une des dispositions consiste rien
moins qu'à créer dans chaque école et
chaque collège et j'espère de macha
crise et pour l'instant c'est les
collèges et lycées une équipe d'environ
5 personnes
spécifiquement formés et aptes à la fois
à soutenir la victime parce que on en a
path est pas suffisamment pas où est la
première des choses dont les victimes
ont besoin c'est d'être au sein même de
leur établissement
réconforté soutenu avoir le cadre d'une
écoute empathique et bienveillante qui
soit là vraiment pour les pour les
soutenir ça c'est la première des aides
des choses et en même temps cette équipe
est également formé pour ainsi que ça a
été dit tout à l'heure pour arrêter les
brimades c'est à dire travailler avec
ceux qui prennent part aux brimades en
les plaçant situation de d'être même
inquiet pour ceux qui ce pour ce qui se
produit donc je pense que si on arrive à
avoir un maillage de ce type sur tout le
territoire une équipe moi je on m'aurait
dit ça il ya quelques années j'aurais
pas cru que c'était possible mais une
équipe par par établissement ce serait
vraiment là on aurait tous les moyens de
de te faire stopper le harcèlement lucie
pitiot dans cette équipe il ya des
enseignants l'a bien compris il ya des
élèves aussi forcément non des adultes
c'étaient les adultes
classe par exemple jouer un rôle c'est à
dire que le programme fasse un programme
complet à la fois il va s'agir de
effectivement sensibiliser les
personnels vous disiez tout à l'heure
mais enfin il forcément ils ont dû
repéré quelque chose ces enseignants
autour de cette jeune fille dont jeu
dont je prenais un exemple tout à
l'heure en fait ils n'ont pas interprété
ce qu'ils avaient sous les yeux parce
que justement ce sont des professeurs de
lycée j'ai la chance d'avoir une d'être
la responsable de détection d'un caddie
à un collège et un lycée autant les
professeurs de collège avait déjà été
sensibilisés à la méthode les
professeurs de lycée ne l'avait pas été
bien nous l'avons fait jeudi dernier
voilà qui est voilà qui est réparé de
façon alors alors permettre et c'est
justement à la lecture de la situation
qu'on avait qu'on avait vécu ensemble de
ne pas retrouver dans ce type de travers
alors dans ces équipes voilà il ya donc
il ya donc pas mal de gens mais il ya
aussi des informations à destination des
familles il y à aussi la formation
d'ambassadeur collégiens c'est là où je
voulais en venir les élèves collégiens
et les élèves lycéens peuvent participer
à un programme où ils deviennent
eux-mêmes ambassadeurs de la lutte
contre le contre le harcèlement et puis
participe à sensibiliser classe par
classe et parfois même d'un niveau à un
anneau c'est à dire des lycéens vont
aller former des collégiennes et
collégiens vont dans les écoles
primaires parce qu'on en parlait tout à
l'heure mais les écoles primaires par
exemple une académie comme strasbourg
c'est 50% des cas de harcèlement que
l'on détecte ce qui est colossal au
niveau départemental et à quelle est
donc vous dites comme pauline de
villoutreys soute à l'heure c'est plus
en plus jeunes c'est de plus en plus
jeunes alors 5 6 ans je n'ai pas observé
ceci étant il n'était pas rare d'avoir
des situations de cm1 cm2 y compris qui
met en jeu les réseaux sociaux mais ça
on en reparlera je m'en vais pas
renvoyer mire tout de suite revenir aux
équipes effectivement ce ne sont que des
adultes ce qui n'empêche pas à la fois
les familles d'être informé et les
enfants de
s'impliquer dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement quelques chiffres sur le
cyber harcèlement 25 % des collégiens 14
% des lycéens déclarent en avoir été
victime
ça veut dire un collégien sur quatre qui
dit avoir été cyber harceler pauline
2013 est ce que c'est le principal
phénomène sur lequel vous êtes saisis
aujourd'hui avec votre association est
ce que c'est d'abord du cyber
harcèlement ou est ce que il ya toujours
du cyberharcèlement quand on parle de
harcèlement si je me fais bien
comprendre
alors d'abord on a bien évidemment du
harcèlement scolaire et on a bien
évidemment après les violences sur
internet qu'on apporte donc j'ai six
barres violence qui viennent juste après
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui avec les
saints domaine du numérique qui commence
à prendre de plus en place dans notre
quotidien on s'est rendu compte que
finalement les enfants avaient accès de
plus en plus tôt aux écrans qui n'était
pas forcément guide et on leur a pas
expliqué finalement comment ça
fonctionnait donc ce qui fait que on se
rend compte que finalement le cyber
harcèlement va être aujourd'hui de plus
en plus présent justement avec ce que je
disais puis aussi avec les différents
confinement qu'on a eue avec la crise
sanitaire les enfants avaient un accès
aux moyens plus simples aux écrans ce
qui fait qu'ils passaient plus de temps
par exemple sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les jeux internet ce qui fait que donc
les phénomènes de cyber harcèlement
n'était pas finalement rares au
contraire ils se sont multipliés et on
s'en rend compte que finalement un
enfant non seulement va être harcelé à
l'école mais il rentre chez lui ce sera
pas la paix puisque le harcèlement va
continuer sur ces sur son téléphone en
fait on lui du coup la pulsion qu'on va
lui demander ses c'est de bloquer de
signaler sauf que lui par exemple ne
sait pas forcément comment faire ses
parents encore moins donc c'est vraiment
indispensable qu'aujourd'hui on guide
d'abord les parents qui sont parfois
responsables souvent du cyberharcèlement
que leurs enfants subissent pour ensuite
expliquer à leurs enfants comment on se
sert d'un téléphone premièrement et
ensuite comment essayer de faire face à
cette cyber violences qu'ils subissent
de plein fouet évidemment la secousse
que ça change c'est que le harcèlement
ça va être plus à la porte de l'école ça
peut ça continue malheureusement souvent
dans les heures qui suivent via les
médias sociaux sabine van dijk de c'est
évidemment là la question elle se pose
aussi pour
l'effet que news les menaces de mort de
la question de la responsabilité des des
plateformes alors c'est sans doute pas
au niveau du sénat au niveau du
parlement au niveau du gouvernement
français c'est au niveau européen
peut-être vous faut essayer de tendre un
peu le bras des plateformes qui met pas
les moyens pour modérer et qu'elle très
clairement certes mais moi j'ai j'ai
présenté lors de l'examen du texte au
sénat un amendement qui a été votée
d'ailleurs qui portent obligations
prestataires des services du nhs est de
lutter contre le harcèlement
avec avec aussi une obligation de
d'insérer des deux c'est simple des
courtes vidéos qu'ils apparaissent sur
les écrans des enfants indiquant les
bonnes pratiques du net sont des choses
quand même facile à faire et qui peuvent
qui peuvent à force à force de
répétition impacter positivement
des enfants ils sont complètement
victimes oui vous avoue semblé douter
mais non mais malheureusement c'est ça
va ça va au-delà de la question donc
l'europe c'est l'europe qui doit bien
sûr gérer ça et on compte sur la
présidence française de l'union
européenne pour qu'elle se saisisse de
cette question a une responsabilité des
plateformes qui est gigantesque mais
il devrait avoir les moyens de stopper
eu ce qu'on appelle les phénomènes de
fleming c'est à dire lorsque un garçon
ou une fille et le soir souvent ça se
passe la nuit et littéralement incendié
agoni d'injures dans l'espace de très
peu de temps par un groupe puis après
d'autres qui viennent de ceux qui
viennent s'agréger ils ont tous les
arabes le rite qui leur permettent de
d'identifier ce genre de choses il
faudrait que les comptes à ce moment là
soit bloquée donc il y aurait une espèce
d espace de non droit qui est celui des
des réseaux sociaux dans lequel
nécessairement il se passe des choses
terrifiantes les jeunes gens en sont les
premières victimes
on leur a légué comme ça un téléphone
avec tous les risques que cela que cela
comporte moi je pense au temps sur la
question du harcèlement j'allais dire
plus plus classique celui du harcèlement
scolaire je pense que on a très
sérieusement avancé autant sur celui du
cyberharcèlement il ya tout un chantier
à entreprendre kg quand est ce que les
mails ici pitiot zappa en diabolisant
nous ici et les médias sociaux et je
suis d'accord avec vous un que on va
trouver la solution parce que le rapport
de cette génération à leur image ou même
à leur intimité pas un autre
radicalement changer modifier le rapport
à l'intimé avant on pouvait dire un
enfant l'intime c'est ce que tu fais
seule dans chaque chambre maintenant
seul dans la chambre ça n'existe pas
parce qu'il ya le smart et le smartphone
avec avec l'enfant la plupart du temps
malheureusement il faut qu'on soit quand
même assez clair par rapport à ça il
existe des règles même vis-à-vis des des
comptes sur les réseaux sociaux en
théorie c'est pas avant de 13 ans pour
snam chat et ouvriers pas avant 16 ans
pour le web ça pour ne cesse de répéter
aux familles du